haha Evan just kidding and then I'm the
green legend is the power of three go
okay happy weekend everybody hi yeah
yeah we've got we got Hayden Green Green
Lantern Hayden I green lantern with the
power of we've got his cousin Superman
Jeffrey haha she later we're opening a
package why it says fragile do not been
cool that one of my YouTube subscribers
sent along who wants to open the package
me okay open it together Wow package for
my youtube subscriber open it up oh it's
an Evan we got a Steve Jobs doll and
we've got coming Evan too there's a
heaven and see time Steve Jobs there
they are so the idea here is you can
turn anything you want your picture your
friends into a little stop star and it's
wet what's the website soap stars combo
include it in the description below and
there's a whole bunch of famous people
you can get Bob Marley Marilyn Manson
Elvis Presley Boy George Steve Jobs or
Evan Carmichael I guess if you want so
that's got the belief shirt yeah the
game it's got oh it's got three stars
hey
sorry that's interesting oh look at my
roaches I don't want this is funny then
anyway okay so we can chaos happening
here thank you guys for watching go
check out sup stars calm how about
amazing have an amazing weekend and let
me and believe